Did you know that no emotion lasts
longer than 90 seconds unless you feed
it? That's right. Your anger, anxiety,
or sadness naturally dissipates in just
a minute and a half. When emotions
trigger, your body releases chemicals
that flush out within 90 seconds, unless
you keep the circuit going with your
thoughts. This isn't just positive
thinking. It's neuroscience discovered
at
Harvard. Next time you feel overwhelmed,
try this. Notice the physical sensations
in your body. Count to 90 while
breathing deeply. Don't fight the
feeling. Just observe it passing through
you like a wave. You'll literally feel
the intensity
subsiding. Your emotions don't make your
decisions, but they sure are convincing
salespeople. Emotions are like weather
systems. They always pass if you don't
fight against them. This simple
awareness gives you incredible power.
You're no longer at the mercy of
emotional storms because you understand
their temporary nature. The tools to
master your mind are waiting for you.
This will find you when you need it
most.